parteichefs in not nach dem vale klar in
thüringen müssen sich die
bundesvorsitzenden von cdu und fdp
rückendeckung bei ihren eigenen
parteigremien holen
ratlosigkeit in thüringen gestern hatte
ministerpräsident thomas kemmerich
seinen rückzug angekündigt heute wird er
doch erstmal im amt bleiben
tod einer symbolfigur der arzt leven
young hatte frühzeitig vor dem ausbruch
des corona virus gewarnt jetzt ist auch
er am virus gestorben und die wut der
chinesin wächst die nachrichten nicht
alles sollte mit christian sievers guten
abend hinein an diesem freitag hier ist
ihr nachrichtenüberblick der sportliche
teil nachher mit norbert könig genannt
wir beginnen mit dem was der wahl eklat
von thüringen in der bundespolitik
angerichtet hat gleich zwei parteichefs
die sich in ihren eigenen reihen
versichern mussten ob sie noch genügend
rückhalt haben
bei cdu und fdp gab es krisensitzungen
und bei beiden am ende unterstützung für
die vorsitzenden
es bleiben aber viele fragen
insbesondere wie es weitergeht vor ort
in thüringen
wir beginnen heute abend mit der lage
bei cdu und fdp in berlin und mit
florian neumann
es ist ihr versuchen die offensive zu
kommen
nach tagen der kritik will die
cdu-chefin heute den bei spd und grünen
spielen
wir erwarten dass es eine bereitschaft
von spd und grünen gibt einen kandidaten
oder eine kandidatin zu präsentieren
der oder die als ministerpräsident oder
ministerpräsidentin nicht das land
spaltet sondern das land ein
am abend zuvor ist kramp karrenbauer
selbst nach erfurt gereist um mit der
cdu fraktion im thüringer landtag über
die lage zu diskutieren
ein stundenlanger machtkampf den kramp
karrenbauer am ende verliert sie fordert
neuwahlen
die parteifreunde vor ort folgen ihr
nicht obwohl die stimmung in der
bundes-cdu auch heute eindeutig ist
neuwahlen wären in dieser situation aus
meiner sicht der klarste schritt nach
vorn
zur gleichen stunde ein weiterer versuch
eines parteichefs die eigene macht zu
sichern
fdp chef christian lindner gewinnt die
von ihm gestellte vertrauensfrage im
präsidium seiner partei deutlich mit 33
von 36 stimmen und gibt sich zugleich
zerknirscht nachdem die wahl des
fdp-politikers kemmerich mit stimmen
auch aus der afd
viele irritiert hatte diese zweifel an
der grundlegenden orientierung unserer
partei bedauern wir zutiefst
wie weiter in thüringen christian
lindner fordert neuwahlen das kann sich
auch die spd spitze vorstellen
oder dass die cdu den linken bodo
ramelow unterstützt
es gibt einen wahlsieger das ist
anzuerkennen und die cdu muss jetzt
entscheiden ob sie diesen kandidaten
verhindern will oder nicht verhindern
will morgen krisen koalitionsausschuss
in berlin das beben von thüringen wird
nach in die hauptstadt dem es noch mal
durch gemeinsam mit gunther love energy
schokotaler vielleicht erst die fdp
christian lindner bedauert heute
zutiefst dass da zweifel an der
grundhaltung der fdp entstanden sind ist
damit aus dem schneider
also er persönlich schon die parteien
noch nicht er hat ja von bundesvorstand
sehr sehr starke rückendeckung bekommen
33 von 36 stimmen im vertrauens in der
vertrauensfrage für ihn das ist schon
ein starkes votum ist vielleicht auch
ein bisschen aus der not heraus geboren
denn in zwei wochen sind hamburg
in hamburg waren da will die fdp
bestehen die steht momentan nach der
letzten umfrage bei fünf prozent
das wird sehr knapp und unter diesen
umständen wirklich ein
nervenaufreibendes rennen da müssen
jetzt alle zusammen halten hört man aus
dem umfeld der fdp und da schließen sich
jetzt eben die kräfte um dort das
schlimmste zu verhindern
und dann die cdu die cdu chefin hat
heute gesagt man warte auf einen neuen
kandidaten von spd und grünen in
thüringen
ursprünglich hatte sie einmal neuwahlen
gefordert wie erfolgreich war den
annegret kramp karrenbauer in ihrem
bestreben den landesverband auf linie zu
bringen
ja wenn man sie an ihren eigenen
aussagen ist eben nicht sie ist ja
hingereist mit der aussage neuwahlen
seien die beste lösung diese lösung hat
sie nicht bekommen von der fraktion die
fraktion setzt lieber auf einen zweiten
anlauf im landtag und diesen vorschlag
in richtung spd und grüne der den
koalitionspartner spd sehr erbost da hat
norbert walter borjans heute schon
gesagt die cdu solle bitte aus dem weg
gehen und neue den weg für neuwahlen
freimachen
also das wird noch einiges an
diskussionsstoff geben das soll ja hier
auch morgen im koalitionsausschuss
zwischen union und spd besprochen werden
also wenn man das nimmt ist sie nicht
erfolgreich gewesen sie hat ja auch hier
im zdf gesagt es geht um die
glaubwürdigkeit der christdemokraten
die hat sie mit ihrer fahrt nach
thüringen und mit den gesprächen mit
thüringen noch nicht wieder herstellen
können die situation in berlin dank und
allah und wie jetzt weiter in thüringen
erstmal muss müsste ministerpräsident
thomas kemmerich den weg für einen
nachfolger freimachen
der fdp mann ließ aber heute wissen ein
sofortiger rücktritt sei zitat nicht
geboten so viele wichtige entscheidungen
stünden an
jetzt soll der ältestenrat des landtages
zusammenkommen möglichkeiten gibt es
einige neuwahlen sind dabei jetzt doch
eher unwahrscheinlich geworden michael
bewerunge eigentlich wollte
ministerpräsident thomas kemmerich heute
die landtagspräsidentin treffen um
seinen als baldigen rückzug vom amt zu
besprechen sagte er
doch dann die nächste wollte im
thüringischen wal drama kemmerich will
erstmal bleiben die juristen der
landtagsverwaltung und der staatskanzlei
sind darüber einig dass ein rückzug
zum beispiel sofort nicht geboten ist da
es wichtige entscheidungen der
landesregierung gibt für die es zu
mindestens ein amtierendes
regierungsmitglied braucht für die linke
ein untragbarer zustand
wenn schon jetzt kann er nicht
zurücktritt ist der geschäftsführend im
amt
und wir können am gleichen tag mit
seinem rücktritt wenn der wirksam ist
einen neuen ministerpräsidenten ohne
eine neue regierung wählen
also insofern sind das eines
vorgeschobenen argumenten nur um seine
zeit um zu verlängern
dafür hat sich inzwischen die cdu im
land zu zwei schritten durchgerungen
fraktionschef mohring muss bis mai
zurücktreten und stadt neuwahlen will
die union in einem erneuten urnengang
die wahl von bodo ramelow nicht mehr
verhindern sondern ermöglichen
im ersten wahlgang werden wir einen
ministerpräsidenten ramelow natürlich
nicht mitwählen auch im zweiten wahlgang
nicht und im dritten wahlgang besteht ja
dann die möglichkeit dass man sich
möglicherweise auch enthalten kann damit
auch nicht parteitagsbeschlüsse umgeht
am abend demonstrierten in erfurt auch
heute wieder hunderte gegen die wahl des
ministerpräsidenten mit stimmen der afd
und forderten thomas kemmerich auf
sofort von seinem amt zurückzutreten
guck mal noch kurz laufen nach erfurt zu
melanie haack meine guten abend das
wirkt er jetzt doch eher zäh obwohl alle
versprochen hatten schnell klarheit zu
schaffen
wie sähe denn jetzt das
wahrscheinlichste szenario aus für
thüringen ja also in der tat es sieht
wirklich erst mal so aus nachdem die cdu
ja gesagt hat keine neuwahlen ist es
zumindest jetzt erst einmal soweit dass
die parteien hier miteinander reden die
cdu mit der linken die grünen mit der
cdu und jörg emmerich hat ja gesagt er
wird sein amt erst mal nicht niederlegen
und das ist ja auch wirklich das
interessante er ist tatsächlich in der
tat im moment der einzige das einzige
amtierende regierungsmitglied und die
frage ist natürlich wie wird es
weitergehen er will eigentlich nach wie
vor das parlament auflösen aber
wahrscheinlicher wird eine
vertrauensfrage eben sein und dann und
das ist wirklich das neue heute auch an
diesem tag hat die cdu ja gesagt dass
sie sich der stimme enthalten wird und
damit
wäre der weg frei für bodo ramelow der
jetzt auch gerade sich noch mal gemeldet
zu wort gemeldet hat und auch gesagt hat
er ist gegen neuwahlen und stehe bereit
für eine neue wahl zumindest präsidenten
jetzt erstmal zum fahrplan das ist ja
mal gut wenn man ein hat am 18
februar tag der ältestenrat des landtags
und dort entscheiden die juristen wie es
in welchem verfahren weitergeht heißt
solange weiterhin erstmal hängepartie
wir sind gespannt wie es weitergeht in
thüringen melanie herzlichen dank und
wie kommt all das bei den deutschen an
einer antwort auf diese frage gibt das
brandneue zdf politbarometer und
matthias fornoff namen matthias hallo
genannt nach den turbulenten tagen in
erfurt haben wir an der blitzumfrage
gemacht und gefragt ob es richtig war
dass thomas kemmerich die wahl
angenommen hat die ja nur mit den
stimmen der afd möglich war ein drittel
sagt ja das war in ordnung so eine
mehrheit von 58 prozent aber findet das
nicht richtig
auch die cdu hat kemmerich ja mit
gewählt obwohl die partei eine klare
beschlusslage hat nicht mit fdp oder
linke zu kooperieren nicht mit der
linken zusammenzuarbeiten finden 40
prozent richtig 50 prozent falsch klara
das bild bei einer zusammenarbeit der
cdu mit der afd
das lehnen mehr als drei viertel der
deutschen ab interessante zahlen jetzt
die ganz anderes thema weltweit geht die
angst um vor dem corona virus wir
berichten gleich in dieser sendung
zunächst die frage an dich wie sehr
beschäftigt dass die deutschen die sind
im moment was das betrifft ziemlich
entspannt es gibt ja auch noch nicht so
viele fälle im land die eigene
gesundheit ist nicht gefährdet das sagen
90 prozent und 80 prozent glauben dass
bei uns genug gegen die ausbreitung des
virus getan wird
zwei drittel erwarten übrigens dass die
ausbreitung des corona virus der
weltwirtschaft gar nicht so stark
schaden wird mit jetzt vielen dank und
alle zahlen des zdf politbarometers gibt
es im heute journal ab 22 uhr und
natürlich schon jetzt auf heute.de dort
finden sie auch weitere interessante
daten der aktuellen umfrage unter
anderem wer sind
aktuell die zehn wichtigsten politiker
meinungsfreiheit das wort macht in china
massiv die runde im moment zur trauer
kommt wut
anlass ist der tod eines arztes doktor
lieben lernen hatte als einer der ersten
vor dem ausbruch eines gefährlichen
virus gewarnt war aber von polizei und
behörden mundtot gemacht worden
auch doktor lee hat sich selbst
infiziert und ist gestern abend
gestorben
die umstände werfen fragen auf und sie
heizen die kritik am system in china an
dass vertuscht und keine abweichende
meinung zulässt doktor lee hat einen
satz benutzt den viele chinesen jetzt
zitieren
ich denke eine gesunde gesellschaft
sollte nicht nur eine stimme haben
aus peking stefanie schöneborn dr
wenn lernen ist gestorben die wut über
seinen tod verbreitet sich im
chinesischen netz und sie ist laut wie
sonst nie ein pfeifkonzert inhuman für
den whistleblower dr
sie stellen kerzen in die fenster für
den arzt der schon ende dezember vor dem
corona virus warnte er ist von uns
gegangen als wir ihn am meisten
brauchten um das corona virus und die
dadurch verursachte lungenentzündung zu
bekämpfen
er ist auch ein opfer des virus geworden
und dann wurde er auch noch dafür
kritisiert und unfair behandelt weil er
die wahrheit über das virus
veröffentlicht hat wir sind alle sehr
traurig leben lang wird am ersten januar
von der polizei in wien einvernommen
muss ein dokument unterschreiben dass er
keine gerüchte mehr über das virus
verbreitet doch die wahrheit holt den
unterdrückungsapparat 1
der arzt erkrankt wie viele tausende an
dem virus der blogger funding zeigt wie
dramatisch die situation in woran ist
leichensäcke stapeln sich in einem
krankenwagen auch er verbreitet
angeblich gerüchte wurde festgenommen
und verhört
die regierung bedankt sich nicht bei uns
die lässt uns festlegen
das zeigt wie die leute behandelt die
wahrheit sagen liebe in lyon hat auch
die wahrheit gesagt und wie wurde er
behandelt leben lang ist gestern nacht
gestorben zehn tage nachdem die
krankheit beim ausgebrochen ist
er war 34 jahre alt im netz wird offen
die frage gestellt warum er so jung und
offenbar gesund gestorben ist wenn
offiziell das virus doch nur für alte
und kranke gefährlich sei die epidemie
hat ein gesicht bekommen und bringt die
chinesische regierung in erklärungsnot
auch auf dem für japan in quarantäne
liegenden kreuzfahrtschiff diamond
princess greift das virus um sich 41
neue infektionen wurden jetzt
nachgewiesen damit erhöht sich die
gesamtzahl der fälle auf dem schiff auf
61 die betroffenen werden von bord
gebracht in krankenhäuser
mehr als 100 menschen zeigen symptome
und werden untersucht fast 3700 müssen
weiterhin auf dem schiff bleiben
mindestens noch bis zum 19
februar etwa die hälfte von ihnen sind
japaner 10 sind deutsche in die usa und
zu den vorwahlen der demokraten in ios
da hatte ja eine technische panne bei
der stimmenauszählung für chaos gesorgt
jetzt drei tage später hat die partei
ein endergebnis verkündet und danach
liegt der frühere bürgermeister piet
buyse hauchdünn vor dem senator bernie
sanders
die parteiführung will die stimmen aber
noch mal nachzählen lassen um so sagt
sie das öffentliche vertrauen
sicherzustellen
seit dem brett vor einer woche hat sich
auch dies geändert ohne briten gibt es
in der eu nur noch eine einzige
atommacht frankreich
und so sieht präsident emanuel makro
sein land in einer zentralen rolle was
die gemeinsame verteidigungsstrategie
betrifft mit einer grundsatzrede machte
er das heute klar führen will er
militärisch aber gerne im dialog mit
anderen ländern christel haas die
marseille es für den präsidenten und
oberbefehlshaber der streitkräfte
im manual marco hat ganz bewusst die
école de geer
die militärische kaderschmiede gewählt
um seine position zur verteidigung
vorzustellen
makro malt ein düsteres bild der
sicherheitslage
deshalb müsse europa autonom werden in
sachen verteidigung ohne aber die nato
in frage zu stellen so rupp die europäer
könnten sehr schnell mit einem
konventionellen oder atomaren wettrüsten
auf ihrem eigenen boden konfrontiert
werden sie dürfen sich nicht auf die
rolle des zuschauers beschränken
all dies bietet makro kritisierte dass
europa in den letzten 20 jahren seine
verteidigungsanstrengungen
zurückgefahren habe angesichts der
aktuellen krisen im irak oder in der
sahel zone sei das ein fehler gewesen
frankreich schickt deshalb 600
zusätzliche soldaten nach mali und nicht
nur das ich habe entschieden dass eine
noch nie da gewesene budget anstrengung
im bereich der verteidigung vorgenommen
wird es wird eine große und dauerhafte
maßnahme sein
es war die rede eines mannes der mehr
europa bei der verteidigung will und
sich gleichzeitig als vorreiter sieht
doch seine schärfsten kritiker stehen
schon parat die europäischen länder
helfen uns nicht genug
ob material truppen oder finanzielle
unterstützung und die eu die gehört zu
den ewig abwesenden
der präsident nutzte derweil die
gelegenheit im persönlichen gespräch mit
offiziers schülern für seine vision zu
werben
jetzt ist es an den eu-partnern zu
reagieren
und den überblick beim sport gibt uns
jetzt norbert ja zunächst noch mal mit
einem trainerwechsel der wirklich immer
noch für reichlich gesprächsstoff sorgt
alfred gislason langjähriger coach des
deutschen rekordmeisters thw kiel soll
nun also als nachfolger von christian
prokop die nationalmannschaft im
handball der männer zu den olympischen
spielen führen
er tritt als erster ins rampenlicht
alfred gislason der neue bundestrainer
neben ihm nach dem überraschenden
trainer beben gestern fast die komplette
dhb spitze hatten sie den bisherigen
verantwortlichen christian prokop nach
platz fünf bei der em noch den rücken
gestärkt nun die kehrtwende innerhalb
des präsidiums ist zu dem entschluss
gekommen dass der erfolg mit einfach
gisler sondern wahrscheinlicher ist für
den schon 2016 vom dhb umworben den
isländer ist der job als nationaltrainer
eine neue erfahrung nach 22 jahren
höchst erfolgreicher vereinstätigkeit
kesslers an den deutschen handball
viel zeit bleibt nicht bis zum olympia
qualifikationsturnier im april alle
haben das auch gemacht dass ich mich gut
kennen und wissen wie er wollte die
erwartungen sind groß denn das
herausgegebene ziel für tokio ist eine
olympische medaille gut ein vierteljahr
am abend zwischenbilanz stark mit vier
punkten rückstand auf die spitze hatte
hansi flick den cheftrainerposten beim
fc bayern übernommen am sonntagabend
nach dem topspiel der bundesliga gegen
rb leipzig könnten es vier punkte
vorsprung sein
vorteil bayern zum beispiel im duell der
torjäger lewandowski 22 werner 20 das
momentum einem titelverteidiger der
schon das hinspiel bestimmte das 1 0
durch lewandowski die münchner krise die
komatsu entlassung brachte damals noch
fern
leipzigs glücklicher punkt durch
rosbergs elfmetertor
für viele ist das hier die sogenannte
endspiel
davon möchte ja nicht nichts wissen weil
es sie noch dann als insgesamt 14
spieler lassen
13 spiele die gespielt werden müssen
selbst 100 prozent reichen manchmal
nicht wenn sie im ganz normalen tag
haben 100 auch manchmal zu wenig der
verlust der tabellenführung das aus im
pokal leipzig hat nun die mini krise
die bayern trafen zuletzt besser und
wollen die poleposition zementieren
auch in champions league und dfb-pokal
noch zu schlagen
bei vielen dank sehr gerne ich lege
ihnen jetzt noch den blick aufs wetter
ans herz morgen wird es noch mal schön
aber danach kommt ein echter sturm
details von gunther tiersch heute
journal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
um 22 uhr morgen freut sich petra
gerster hierauf sie von mir danke fürs
interesse und vom gesamten heute 19 team
in allen einen angenehmen haptik
[Musik]
unglaubliche zuschauer erst am sonntag
kommt der sturm morgen wird es noch mal
ganz angenehm bei uns aber von westen
würde uns bereits eine erste wolkenfront
erreichen aber sie bringt wohl noch kein
regen und gleichzeitig wird hier das
westwind band über dem atlantik stärker
ein tief hat sich dann eingelagert
das bringt uns sonntag und montag sturm
und orkanböen in mitteleuropa heute
nacht ist noch alles ruhig klarer himmel
ein paar nebelfelder haben wir im süden
auch im nordosten vielleicht
wolkenlücken und es wird kalt wieder
frostig im norden um 0 grad sonst minus
2 bis minus 5 an den alpen minus zehn
grad morgen wird es tatsächlich etwas
milder als heute meist sind das fünf bis
zehn grad im westen allerdings 11 bis 13
oder 14 grad und es wird noch die sonne
scheine im osten und süden vor allem im
westen setzt dann schon die bewölkung
ein so von etwa von der eifel bis zur
nordsee starke wirkung am nachmittag es
bleibt trocken und der wind frischt im
norden etwas auf und dann kommt der
sturm am sonntagmorgen im nordwesten am
nachmittag dann erste orkanböen auch in
der mitte deutschlands und in der nacht
zieht er dann weiter am montagmorgen ist
auch der mine und die alpen dran sturm
und orkanböen und das wetter ziemlich
lustig ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut